in 2022 Netflix released a movie called
White Noise the plot while it takes
place in a little town in Ohio a train
passing through the town gets derailed
and it spills a bunch of toxic chemicals
into the air the Resonance of the Town
had to Fleet as they were breathing in
toxic air and coincidentally a year
after that movie was released was
started as fiction turned into real life
smoke plumes trains Stacks side by side
all on fire state of emergency in Ohio
after a massive train derailment in East
Palestine Ohio a fright Shrine with
tankers of toxic chemicals derailed and
caught fire lighting up the night sky
releasing thousands of gallons of
hazardous chemicals into the air forcing
residents to evacuate police car came up
and said evacuate evacuate evacuate now
get out get out it's an almost
apocalyptic scene
the simulation has been broken and
there's a massive cover-up happening
right now it's just before 9 pm on
Friday February 3rd 2023 a train
carrying 20 cars of hazardous chemicals
passes through the town of Salem Ohio as
the train speeds through the night no
one notices the Sparks and Flames
underneath one of its cars and after a
few more miles disaster strikes
residents of East Palestine hear the
training Roar into town but then
suddenly a loud screeching fills the
error followed by the sound of a massive
crash 50 train cars derail in a fiery
Blaze just outside a residential
neighborhood and 20 of the trace tankers
were filled with different types of
potent chemicals all spewing into the
ground it was a toxic disaster that
America had not seen in a very long time
but the authorities weren't going to let
that truth slip out so in the days that
followed those in charge made one
questionable Choice after another first
they evacuated residents thousands of
residents under a mandatory evacuation
order police going door to door
threatening families with children with
a rest if they don't leave police car
came up and said evacuate evacuate
evacuate now get out get out it smells
like really really strong paint thinner
and then his eyes turned like bloodshot
and he started coughing and I was like
yeah we're leaving then they set fire to
the highly toxic chemicals in a
controlled release that formed this
giant cloud of toxic gas over the town
days after the derailment the EPA was
forced to admit that the train may have
been carrying much more toxic chemicals
than first reported but for some reason
they told everyone it was safe to return
officials declared that the air and
water were definitely safe but as
residents returned they started
experiencing strange symptoms like their
throats burning they witnessed fish and
frogs dying in the streams animals were
acting weird at least 11 of the cars
that derailed carried the carcinogen
Vinyl chloride along with other
chemicals used to make adhesives
Plastics and construction materials if
someone breathes in high levels of
something like Vinyl chloride they might
experience headaches dizziness and
increased risk of developing certain
types of cancer residents who have
returned to the evacuation Zone have
reported headaches and rashes
respiratory issues and coughing I can't
even put it into words I was in tears
over the headache that I had last night
symptoms I also noticed that I have this
rash on my arm that was not there before
I came here it doesn't smell safe I'm
taking my things and I'm out of here I
have heard that they have got two dogs
that actually drank out of there and
died yeah I have headaches I mean I and
then the other night when I was coming
home from work I was coming down through
candleton I could smell they're down
there you know my grandkids see the
whole lives
happening for like upwarded a date okay
in different places because they're
afraid to come home okay and I thought
maybe they were exaggerating yeah until
I went there just now yeah my husband
and it was like oh my God like we had to
get out of there it's bad yeah
it became very clear that this was the
worst man-made disaster America had seen
in years and yet for almost two weeks
there was a media blackout on it you'd
think a disaster of the size would be
front page news but no one seemed to
care no National newspapers reported on
it no mainstream media mentioned it not
even the Secretary of Transportation
Pete Boo the judge said a word about
what happened and for good reason a
disaster of this proportion means that
there's a lot of money on the line a lot
of lawsuits on the line and as it turns
out BlackRock owns major shares in both
the railway company and the mainstream
media Outlets hmm interesting stay
dangerous and welcome to another glitch
in the simulation
respiratory issues burning eyes and dead
Wildlife including at least 3 500
confirmed dead fish killed by
contamination kind of crazy for a small
town like this
[Music]
BlackRock owns a lot of stocks and if
you want some free stocks you can get up
to 12 free stocks when you sign up for
Weeble and deposit any amount with the
link below you can literally deposit as
little as one cents and you'll still get
the free stocks this promotion
definitely isn't going to last forever
and it's really easy to claim so you
might as well do it with the link below
by opening an account you're
automatically going to get two free
stocks each value between three dollars
and 300 and then you'll receive another
four or eight or ten free stocks value
between seven and three thousand dollars
after you make an initial deposit of any
amounts and if you don't know Weeble is
a Great Commission free stock trading
app that is perfect for you to get set
up before the next bull market they
allow you to invest with as little as
five dollars through fractional shares
where you can own a fraction of a stock
from your favorite company or ETF
without committing to a whole share and
they even have a stock trading simulator
where you can hone in your skills
without putting real money on the line
this is great if you're a beginner you
don't have enough funds yet you have the
capital but don't know where to start or
if you want to test Nutri trading
strategies so get up to 12 free Stocks
by pausing the video and clicking the
link below pause the video and click the
link below the claim now thanks to
Weeble for sponsoring this video
what you have to understand is that
although the railroad business may seem
old and antique it's still a big
business Nora folk southern the company
that owns the train that was derailed
made over 12 billion dollars in Revenue
in 2022 but trains are very expensive so
Norfolk Southern had to cut a lot of
Corners more than a thousand train
derailments occur in America every
single year and yet most modern freight
trains still use Civil War era braking
systems including Norfolk Southerns why
because switching out all the Civil War
era breaks on every train car with
modern bricks is super super expensive
so when Regulators try to make safer
modern breaks mandatory in 2014 Norfolk
Southern was one of their biggest
opponents according to them these new
bricks would be extremely expensive
without offering quote offsetting
benefit End quotes translation the
lawsuits and damage caused by railroad
accidents would still cost a lot less
than installing new fancy brakes on
other trains it was a simple cost
benefit analysis and because railroad
transport is so critical to our economy
Norful sudden had a lot of political
sway to prevent that from going through
but that was far from the only way they
cut corners
[Music]
most trains carrying hazardous flammable
materials are required to report the
types quantities and risks associated
with the chemicals they're transporting
but doing that takes time it delays
shipments and ultimately it affects your
bottom line so Norfolk Southern lobbied
against having to do so and where did
they do this lobbying in Ohio according
to them the chemicals on their train
just weren't dangerous enough to Warrant
all the trouble but that is not all when
railroad workers threatened the strike
because they didn't receive enough sick
leave the railroad industry went to
complain to their friends in power so
President Joe Biden and Congress
immediately moved to block their right
to strike passing new laws that Force
the workers to accept an agreement
without any sick days at all outdated
breaks non-existent safety regulations
and overworked employees all contributed
to the derailment of the train in East
Palestine and according to the railroad
workers union the damage car that caused
the derailment could have probably been
noticed if trained terminals weren't so
understaffed but even after the disaster
there was only one thing on the mind of
Norfolk Southern prophets you see the
train that crashed was blocking the
railroad which granted that route to a
halt shipments were being delayed
conscious were being canceled for every
second that that railroad was not
operational Norfolk Southern was losing
money so they had to do everything in
their power to get that railroad back up
and running
[Music]
so we could get a railroad open
on February 6 just two days after the
disaster Norfolk Southern and local
officials started worrying that
something would make the remaining
tankers of toxic chemicals explode the
five tankers they worried about
contained Vinyl chloride a highly
flammable cancer-causing gas that is
used to make plastic if these tankers
caught fire they would not only explode
but they would project a fatal mix of
hydrogen chloride and phosgene over the
entire town botching was a gas used in
World War one and thousands of people
could be killed and the environment
irreversibly damaged but there was only
one problem safely removing the tankers
away from the fire will probably take
weeks weeks where the railroad route
would not be making any money so they
suggested a risky solution do a
controlled burn a controlled explosion
sure you would be burning those
chemicals into the town's error but hey
you would be able to move the tankers
within a few days or a few hours and
that's exactly what happened on Sunday
February 6th more than 8 000 residents
of East Palestine were evacuated from
their homes workers then use small
explosions to blow holes in the five
tankers to empty their contents into a
trench where it was burned away the
controlled release resulted in a massive
plume of dark toxic gas hanging over the
town for hours afterward but it got the
job done the train wreckage was cleared
the officials were able to declare the
town as safe just two days after the
explosion and what do you know the
railroad was back up and running less
than two days later with trains passing
through and all we basically nuked to
town with chemicals so we could get a
railroad open but as the residents
started returning home it didn't take
them long to realize that something was
massively wrong
foreign
[Music]
officials declared that it was perfectly
safe to return home with the full
support and backing of Governor dewine
I'm happy to announce that the
evacuation order is now lifted officials
said that they hadn't found any cost per
concern yet even though the testing was
limited next they declared the water as
safe to drink but then they flip-flopped
what the mayor suggesting that residents
stick to bottled water instead you
should never drink tap water by the way
chemical disaster or not video coming
out soon on the evil food supply Channel
subscribe below and then days after the
crash the EPA suddenly discovered that
there may have been more toxic chemicals
on board than they had initially
thoughts today the EPA said the train
that derailed and caught fire in Ace
Palestine Ohio was carrying and actually
released more toxic chemicals than was
first reported but the people didn't
need the EPA to tell them that because
the residents were suddenly experiencing
headaches nausea rashes vomiting and
finding strange chemicals in their water
so it didn't take long for the entire
town to panic which leaves the residents
of East Palestine in an impossible
situation thanks for the contamination
they can't sell their homes for anything
anymore which means it's hard for many
of them to leave but if they stay they
have to deal with the fact that they
could be poisoning themselves and their
children and that they may not feel the
full effects until decades later and all
the officials involved have been doing
their best to cover it up
[Music]
for two weeks the residents of East
Palestine lived in fear and confusion no
one wanted to talk no one wanted to
share information with them a reporter
was even arrested for getting too loud
during a town hall meeting where the
officials were supposed to answer
questions about the derailments 10 days
after the crash U.S transport secretary
Pete butterjudge spoke to the National
Association of counties and he said
nothing about the crash at all
foreign
U.S Secretary of Transport had nothing
to say about the biggest transport
disaster of our time no major news
organizations reported on it to the rest
of the country it seems like it just
never happened only once people started
returning home and started posting about
it on social media that the rest of the
country actually pay attention and when
you start to look into the players
involved you start to maybe understand
why could it be because one of Norfolk
Southern's major shareholders is
Blackrock could it be because BlackRock
also owns significant percentages in Fox
CBS NBC CNN USA Today and ABC maybe but
you want to know what's even stranger
remember that movie white noise that
predicted this well some of the
residents of East Palestine actually
starred as extras in that movie quote in
real life the Ratner family was one of
the families that evacuated from East
Palestine what was Eerie about their
story is that several Ratner families
had actually Worth US extras on White
Noise they were in a scene where cars
are gridlocked trying to escape the town
in the toxic smoke End quotes but who
knows maybe aliens will finally invade
so we can forget all about this right
now now a new storm is emerging and
Incredibly the culprit may just be
sitting on a shelf in your backyard shed
safety of the country's most popular
weed and grass killer called Roundup
roundup's main ingredient is quote
probably carcinogenic the stuff can kill
you and you want to know what other evil
company deals with toxic chemicals
Monsanto Monsanto are the Evil Geniuses
behind agent orange that was spread over
Vietnam they're behind Roundup and why
you have a bunch of glyphosate in your
body right now and they're behind GMO
crops and because of their genius seed
licensing scheme they practically
control the entire world's food supply
and you can watch our full private
documentary on Monsanto and all its
disturbing Glory by clicking the card on
the screen right now click the card on
the screen to watch now